since the retirement announcement of
Supreme Court Justice Anthony Kennedy
top Democrats have made their support
for unlimited abortion rights a major
campaign issue do we deserve civil
rights in this country do we get to
decide what happens to our bodies how
many children were gonna have where
generations from now our children and
grandchildren will wonder what did we do
what did we do when they were trying to
take away a woman's right to control her
own body
everyone who cares about saving Roe
versus Wade will make their voice heard
right Michael we're directed faith
outreach efforts for the Obama campaign
in 2012 he just wrote an article warning
that quote Democrats are entirely too
focused on abortion end quote and he
recently spoke to Tucker about that
article what did she mean when you said
that that their truest on abortion yeah
sure well there's a range of
implications of cavanaugh filling the
seat that concern Democrats from a
Democratic policy perspective from
immigration to voting rights to
corporate power and workers protections
and yet out of the gate it seemed like
the only thing the Supreme Court was
going to rule on was abortion and you
saw a major activists and even some
Democratic leaders say that the
preeminent focus was on roe v wade which
too many Democratic voters and I think
many Americans seems a bit off certainly
if you're pro-choice you you have a
right to ask questions and impress
Cavanaugh on that like any other issue
but it just seemed to be a bit out of
perspective for me that seems to be a
theme though I mean I think there are
plenty of people who think under certain
certain circumstances abortion ought to
be legal can imagine some circumstances
where it ought to be allowed but aren't
on board for say abortions for sex
selection or third trimester abortion
think there should be some legal limits
some common-sense limits on and think
there are moral implications of it but
that's not the position of the party
anymore why well right I mean I think
you're the party has moved quite a bit
on this issue but it's been a relatively
recent move it used to be that
Democratic Party throughout the party
people called for abortion be safe legal
and rare Barack Obama called as
president for the number of abortions to
be reduced
we actually saw the abortion rate in
this country reach its all-time low
since roe v-- wade under President Obama
so it's not too long ago that you had
Democrats that had a bit more of a
humble approach to the issue of abortion
but something changed and in 2016 for
instance he had Hillary Clinton asked
him the final presidential debate about
our views on late term abortion and
instead of citing the Supreme Court
decision on late term abortion or
instead of saying that abortion should
be safe legal and rare she actually made
an extended case for late term abortion
we also saw in 2016 the Democratic Party
platform for the first time include a
repeal of the Hyde Amendment which bans
federal funding for abortion and these
are these aren't long-standing
Democratic positions and they don't need
to be positions the party carries
forward especially at a time when
Democrats are out of power in so many
places I've met very few people whether
they consider themselves pro-life or
pro-choice who don't think abortion is
sad there's something tragic about it
there is a moral dimension to it no
matter where you are on the spectrum why
not just admit that and why not say you
know we actually don't wash in doesn't
make you happy we don't know what want a
lot of abortions but if you said that
today I think you'd be disqualified in
the Democratic primary well if that's
true then Barack Obama would have to be
disqualified he called abortion a tragic
issue and again he spoke repeatedly to
his desire to see abortions reduce but
it does there is an activist portion of
the party that frankly Democratic
victory seem to be secondary to them as
long as as long as party leaders take
the most unapologetic approach to this
issue as possible and I think that we've
seen the cost for that we've seen the
cost of that in further
Trump being in the Whitehouse we've seen
the costs in someone like Senator Pat
Toomey representing Pennsylvania instead
of Katie McGinty right and you know my
hope as a Democrat would be that the
party would not take that approach in
2018